Today, I want to talk about energy.
Energy is the key, the source of
your success in language learning
and in so many things in life.
And I want to talk about six tips on
how to generate energy within yourself
and how to maintain that energy.
I think I'm allowed to talk about
that because I'm 78 and so I've
lived a lot longer than most of
the people watching this video.
And so I have a lot of life experience.
The first thing about energy
is the more active you are,
the more energy you create.
So while I talk about input in language
learning and the need to bring the
language into you, because you don't
have the language inside you, when it
comes to that energy, which is driving
you to learn a language or to do anything
else, you create that within yourself.
Now, it may be true that some
people are born with more natural
energy, that it's a part of their
makeup more than other people.
However, whatever your sort of
starting point is, your, uh, inherent.
Energy level, you can
improve it by being active.
And so even in terms of business, if
you don't give, if you don't volunteer,
if you don't offer to do things, if you
wait until you get the reward before
you do things, you won't be successful.
You've got to be proactive and
you've got to give before you get.
And if you're active and want to
generate that energy level, you
will be rewarded with more energy.
You're not going to lose
energy by being active.
You have to generate the
It's like your internal dynamo.
So that's point number one.
Second point, you want to be active
both physically and mentally.
The two are related.
So when it comes to language learning,
if you are active physically,
you're going to be more successful.
In your mental activity
of learning a language.
So that means get in the habit
of doing regular exercises.
Every morning I have my
seven minute routine.
It's not a lot, but it's balanced.
I don't know what's coming at me.
Burpees, pushups, you know, crunches,
whatever it might be, I do them.
And there's a double benefit.
A, the benefit that I'm that little
bit fitter for having done that,
but also the sense of satisfaction
that comes from having done it.
Carries with me through the day.
Remember, very often we don't know what
we are achieving, but if we are active
and we sort of tick that one off, I did
my morning exercise, you feel energized,
you feel good for the day, and you
are in fact improving your physical.
Energy source.
Now, the third point is with physical
activity, like working out and language
learning, it's the activity that counts.
If you're running a race, if
you're jogging, you don't need
to be looking over your shoulder.
It's the fact that you're doing it.
That's going to make you feel good.
That's going to give you a
sense of achievement, whether
it's dopamine or serotonin.
I'm not too clear, but
you feel good because.
You did it.
So it's the activity that matters.
And it's the same in language learning.
That's why at LingQ, we don't
try to measure what you have
achieved, how much you improved.
If I spend an hour on LingQ, on my
iPad, looking up words and reading
and listening or whatever I do.
What matters to me is that I did
that activity and I get a sense
of satisfaction, achievement.
I accomplished something.
I put that amount of effort
into my language learning.
That's what matters.
The amount that I improved during that
session, it's hard for me to measure.
So give yourself credit
for actually being active.
You'll get a good feeling.
I did something and that generates energy.
Now number four, try to
control your impulses.
Try to control your.
Ability to resist temptation, if
you are studying, say on your iPad,
develop that ability to resist those
distractions, looking up the email,
looking up Twitter, looking up whatever
other things you follow, don't do it.
Every time you do it, your right
prefrontal cortex is getting
stronger at that ability to
resist temptation and distraction.
If you give in to distraction,
you are weakening that ability
in your prefrontal cortex.
cortex.
So it's very important to be able to
stick with what you're doing, resist
the distractions, and by the same token,
resist the temptation to Eat, you know,
food that you know is not good for you
because good eating, good diet obviously
also contributes to our energy level.
Resist the temptation to fly off
the handle and get mad at someone.
That also saps our energy.
So, developing good habits, helping
your prefrontal cortex get stronger at
resisting these negative temptations
is a good part or an important part of
being full of energy when you need it.
Now, a fifth point in order to maintain
your energy level, vary your activities.
I mentioned my morning routine
because it's an app on my iPhone.
I don't know which
exercises are coming at me.
It's varied.
If it's the same every
day, I would get bored.
It's the same with language learning.
Vary your activities.
And I've discussed before.
The importance of not block learning, of
interleaving, of moving from one content
item to another, mixing in reading a book
with reading on the iPad, uh, mixing in
the listening and the reading, mixing
in advanced material with easy material.
Keep it varied and that'll maintain
your interest level and interest
level equates to energy level.
So vary your activities.
And you will find that your
energy level will be higher.
And finally, another way of ensuring
you always have the energy you need,
is to enjoy what you are doing.
So, for example, in terms of
physical activity, I like to take
the stairs two steps at a time.
It's a way of investing energy.
And activity into maintaining my
energy level, but I enjoy doing it.
I am conscious of taking those two, the
steps two at a time, going up the stairs.
Also look around, enjoy
the colors around you.
Enjoy the texture of the wood or
the whatever, the dress that you see
on someone, the material, enjoy the
scenery, just try to fully appreciate
all the things that surround us and
by the same token, whatever you have
achieved in the language you're learning.
Give yourself credit for it.
Enjoy it.
Enjoy the language.
Enjoy the activity.
Enjoy what you have achieved.
Stay positive.
Stay in the moment.
All of those things will contribute
to a higher energy level.
With that, I'm going to
leave you with two videos.
One deals with the mental side.
Of maintaining your energy level
and not chasing down rabbit holes
and dwelling on negative thoughts,
which maintains our energy level.
And the other one relates
more to physical activity.
And it's one that I did about seven
years ago, and you'll see that
it's quite relevant to this video.
So thank you for listening.
Bye for now.